foreign
cabin I spent about a year building this
by hand with my sons during the
quarantine I chopped down trimmed and
stacked each one of those logs by hand I
actually videoed the entire project from
start to finish I'll put a link down in
the video description below if you want
to see that video it's pretty awesome
looks like we're in pretty good shape
yeah the stove's looking good
oh
oh this could use a little reinforcement
yeah somebody came in here left the door
open
it's a bunch of leaves in here the tin
foil around the stove Jack is falling
out a little bit no leaks no animal
nests this place is looking in pretty
good shape I think I need to do a little
straightening up get camp set up then
get a fire in here
foreign
steel fire starting kit here got my
knife got my Hatchet
taking a wet log and chopping it up is a
great way to get dry kindling when you
need to start a fire in the rain
this right here is fat wood it's a piece
of pine wood that you get out of the
stump of a dead pine tree it's full of
very flammable Pine resin makes great
fire starter I keep a box of it next to
the stove for cold rainy days like today
when it's hard to find dry wood
oh these fat wood shavings smell amazing
they're gonna burn like gasoline
this is a flint Striker I made from a
scrap piece of a car suspension
and this is charred cloth made from a
linen shirt
look at that you got a little ember in
there
let's go and check on the Outhouse too
ah this is the outhouse
well
Outhouse looks good we had some really
big storms last winter and we can see a
lot of trees that are down all over
luckily I picked a good spot nothing
seems to be damaged
my fire pit seems to be buried in the
leaves
though my Bushcraft chair has seen
better days I used kind of rotten wood
for this thing so it didn't last very
long my firewood piles in pretty good
shape though it's been nice to have some
semi dry wood it's kind of getting a
little rotten down there so I think I
need to use it up though
oh
it's gone from really cold to almost
t-shirt weather in here I like this
all right kind of hungry I think it's
time for some lunch you can make myself
some bratwurst
that looks good
all right got some sauerkraut on our
bratwurst now we're gonna put some
mustard
that is very good
took it out that's my canteen I made
from a water buffalo horn
foreign
now they got some lunch in my belly I
think I need to repair the roof one of
my cross members broke under the weight
of the snow last winter so I need to go
and fix that and replace it
gonna need this
foreign
there we go got this fixed got a new
beam running across the roof nice and
strong this is the old piece of the roof
and hopefully that's the only time I
catch the roof on fire
you know something else I need to work
on is the chinking I used mud and straw
before and it worked okay but it's
fallen out in a lot of places you can
just see there's lots of holes I used
bundled up grass and some of the bigger
cracks and it seems to have worked a lot
better so I think I want to do some more
of that
thank you
all right that looks a bit better I've
been packing the cheeking with Ferns and
I'm at a good stopping point which is a
good thing because it's starting to rain
and I don't feel like getting out there
getting wet it's cozy in here looks like
I got a little friend in here with me
hey there little guy
you usually don't see those cockroaches
this time of year but I think warming up
the cabins brought them out but he ain't
bothering anything well guys let me go
ahead and show you my Hatchet here
so this is just a four dollar Hatchet I
went and bought online I went and
stripped the varnish and paint off the
handle
went and burned the handle coated it in
linseed oil polished and sharpened the
head
[Applause]
then went ahead and made a custom sheath
for it
[Music]
then treated the sheath with Oil and
Beeswax
it's just a great little Hatchet and
I've been really pleased with it
[Applause]
all right guys rumor has it that
pineapple juice is one of the best meat
tenderizers ever and so I'm gonna go
ahead and take this steak and put it in
a bag of pulverized pineapple for one
hour and we're gonna see what happens
man I'm really liking this knife the
blade is made by Mora and I got it for
11 bucks and then I put a zebra wood
handle on it with a cow horn collar on
the handle
also made a custom wet formed leather
Sheed for it
and it is just an awesome Bushcraft
knife I really love this this cutting
board is also something I made it's just
a slab of aromatic Cedar and I went and
covered it in food safe resin I've had
it for about three or four years now
it's just an awesome cutting board
I'll tell you what it's really
really there but it is so nice and
toasty in here of dry
I think the only way I can make this
Cozier is if I had something warm to
drink
foreign
[Music]
this is a water skin I made a couple
weeks ago really fun project it's just a
tube of leather that I stitched up the
side and sealed with beeswax and glue
it's got a wood bottom
there we go
well it just let that water warm up
while my steak marinates just kind of
relax take it easy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my goodness I could tell that worked
it's so tenderized
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
baked pineapple baked apple baked yam
sweet carrots asparagus and one very
tender steak I brought all this
wonderful food but I forgot to bring a
fork luckily I got my Camp knife in a
spoon we're gonna make this work
Nora's good state
oh that pineapple is really good too you
know your baked apple and baked yam
there's nothing added to it just it's
just wonderful
yeah I don't mean to brag or anything
but that's a pretty decent medium for
just doing it over a fire
well guys that was wonderful but now
I've got to do the dishes luckily it'll
be pretty easy today
all right
but that's it for a little bit I got
some Peach loose leaf herbal tea here
I've got my cowhorn mug I made
just let that sit and see for a few
minutes
really like these cowhorn mugs a really
easy project to knock out in a couple
hours
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
I also made the spoon out of a piece of
cow horn
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
s I'm in the mood for a little dessert
so I've got this little muffin mix
all right we got a little steel cup
we'll put some blackberries so
blueberries in there got some
gooseberries
a little bit of sugar
foreign
oh it's really coming down out there
oh that looks good to me oh that smells
good
steaming is a great way to bake things
over a fire or a stovetop
oh that's so good
all right it's cold tonight
gonna dry this off put it in my sleeping
bag and it'll keep me toasty warm
tonight double check for leaks
that'll get my sleeping bag nice and
toasty I want some fresh bread in the
morning so I'm gonna go ahead and make
some dough up
sprinkle some yeast
some sugar for the yeast
and then we're gonna pour some water in
got the bread dough mixed up just gonna
let it sit here and Rise it should be
ready in the morning
well guys it is getting late and I am
exhausted
I will see you guys in the morning
oh what a pleasant surprise to wake up
to some blue skies and sunshine I hear
deer down there
I'm hungry I think I should get a fire
started
luckily all that wood I pulled into my
shelter yesterday is all nice and dry
honey butter flatbread couple pork
sausages two sunny side up eggs that is
gorgeous
this little griddle works really well
just a piece of sheet steel and I peen
the edges with a ball peen hammer I took
a bit of 1 8 inch Rod made the handles
and made the rivets
and then I covered the whole thing in
olive oil and seasoned it about eight
times so it's got a nice non-stick
coating just like a bit of cast iron
really quick easy project but man I love
this little griddle if you guys want to
see how I made The Griddle or this knife
or the ax or any other projects I've
mentioned check out the video
description for a link to that video
where I'm actually building the stuff
just making a little mini breakfast
sandwich
oh
that was good
well this has been fun but I think it's
time to start packing up
[Applause]
well this has been a fun little camp out
and I hope you guys enjoyed watching it
if you guys want to see how I made this
log cabin or how I made any of the tools
featured in this video make sure to
check the video description for a link
to those videos and don't forget to
click subscribe to get great new videos
every Saturday morning thanks for
watching guys if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning hit that Bell button
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching
[Music]